[laughter]
[phone dings and vibrates]
Oh, hold on a second.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, hell no.
He did not just text me
he working late.
That shit is weak.
Okay.
You know what,
working late, my ass.
If he don't walk
through that door
in the next half an hour,
he may as well not even
come home tonight
'cause I'm not gonna be there
waiting for his cheating ass.
- Okay!
- All right, girl?
I ain't playing.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean, I will be there
waiting because--
But he gonna have to put up
with a lot of shit from me.
Okay.
And if he think
he gonna do this shit again,
he is sorely mistaken...
Okay!
Because my man
gets one chance.
- Okay!
- One.
- And then after that,
- he get one more...
- Okay...
And then after that,
he gonna get three strikes.
- Then you're out.
- Okay...
And if I ever find out that
my man was messing around on me,
he better get as far
away from me as he possibly can
because he do not want to get
what I'm gonna give to him.
Okay.
I got my motherfucking
real estate license...
Okay!
But if and when he does
come home, that's fine...
Okay.
'Cause he can go out
and get all turnt up
with these little side hos
and whatnot
'cause you know what, bitch?
He always gonna come home.
- All right?
- Okay.
I'm the queen bee, and he
always gonna come home to me.
- You know what?
- Okay...
But you know what, but you
know what, but you know what?
- I don't even care.
- Oh, okay.
But I'll tell you what happen
if he do come home.
Okay.
He ain't gonna be pulling
any of that shit in my house.
Okay...
He can come to the house
if he wants to,
but he ain't never gonna
do that when I'm home.
- Okay.
- You know what?
Even if I'm home,
it's fine.
Okay...
You know
what I'm talking about?
Mm, okay.
'Cause I don't give
a good goddamn.
- Okay.
- That's what I'm talking about.
But he ain't gonna bring
that shit into my bedroom.
I tell you that much right now,
okay?
Okay.
'Cause there ain't no
trifling-ass nigga
gonna wake me up while he's
cheating on me in my bed again.
Okay...
And I told him.
I looked him right in the face.
I said, "This is the fifth
and last time that you"--
Okay!
[exhales]
I couldn't have
said it better myself, girl.
- You're right.
- Okay?
You just been spouting words
of wisdom all evening.
I ain't listening to a
[high-pitched] goddamn thing
you saying.
[quietly]
Okay.
I don't even know what
the hell I was thinking, girl.
You right.
The second that that man
walks through that door,
I'ma dump his ass.
O...kay.
- Okay?
- Okay.
Oh, my gosh,
speak of the devil.
[romantic music]
♪ ♪
O...kay.
Okay.